there's no more red table talk but
according to deadline the series
producer is shopping the Emmy winning
series somewhere else Nick red table
talk may have lots of fans but Nick
Cannon's not one of them I want to be as
transparent as possible Nick weighed in
on the news that Jada Pinkett Smith's
Facebook watch show has been canceled on
his new live radio show The Daily Cannon
it's really like my take on what's going
on in pop culture more specifically he
reflected on Will Smith's appearances on
his wife's show throughout the years you
during that time launched into an
interaction with August what do you feel
like
um you were looking for I just wanted to
feel good it had been so long
since I felt good there was no red table
top then no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no of
course Nick is referring to the now
Infamous incident during the 2022
Academy Awards when will slapped Chris
Rock on live TV after he made a joke
about Jada's shaved head
[__]
but on the flip side Nick's co-hosts
voiced their support for the program
which featured candid conversations and
interviews with Jada her daughter Willow
Smith and her mother Adrian Banfield
Norris we just always want to have just
real conversations we're sharing our
stories when they see us be vulnerable
then they're like oh okay it's it's okay
to be vulnerable but Nick he doubled
down calling the show toxic table was
toxic they made all the memes
they need to do that over the years will
made several emotional appearances on
the program including one notable
sit-down in 2020 where he and Jada
hashed out intimate details about their
relationship I got into an entanglement
with
August that's what I said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely yeah one of the
revelations from their conversation was
that Jada had a romantic entanglement
while she and will were on a break it
takes practice to have those difficult
conversations with kindness and
consideration the more that we can bring
these difficult subjects to light and
talk about it the more we can purify
these subjects and bring them into
something new thumbs up I don't I just
want to mind my black owned business you
can't I don't want to be I don't want to
be up in everybody else kitchen
as for the future of red table talk the
show's Production Company Westbrook
Studios is currently looking for a new
home we've had so many that have
um come and needed to share their
stories
um and felt like red table was the only
place an opportunity to heal opportunity
to make amends an opportunity to share
knowledge that they've gained from a
difficult experience that we can all
learn from you know so I love the shows
that um
hold people up in that way
foreign